[Music]
the Nandina is a species of flowering
plant native to Eastern Asia
smell at certain times of the year gives
you a real Buzz
like the buzz you get
just before pulling the trigger
I have a favorite ask what is it my
grand niece
I would like you to take her Han as an
apprentice
she dropped out of school and then she
ended up in a bad crowd
you'll learn how to garden
are you satisfied with the life that you
have
why would you ask that
you know you talk a lot of but
there's one thing you don't talk about
sad yourself
[Music]
there's not much to know
he puts a deep six on nine bad guys
it was a long time ago
if they're dead you're not forgotten
have you ever killed anyone
[Music]
why would you say that
stuffy shirt
you are impertinent Maya's just finding
her own when I'm the Queen of Scotland
gardening is a belief in the future a
belief that things will happen according
to plan who did this to you what are you
gonna do
trying to start a new life
I have created this life
filled it with rules
now seems the time to break one
[Music]